hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild chess game from the chessboard
british championship it is matthew j
wattsworth versus harry grieve and while
the game is incredible and you guys will
enjoy it before we check out the game uh
there are some news that i am very very
interested in sharing with you as the
title suggests chess.com has uh
made an offer to the play magnus group
to acquire them or rather for the play
magnus group to join the
chess.com and i will put a link to the
uh chess.com article that describes this
um in detail although they didn't really
explain all that much as more uh
information is to come but there is a
very nice video of uh basically an
interview between magnus carlsen and
danny range where you can learn more
about this it's some four minutes and 30
seconds long so
you can check it out it will be the
first thing you see in the description
below so do check it out but basically
for those of you who are maybe
you know lazy to click on other links or
something like that i don't know
they are saying that chess.com is
excited to announce that we have
submitted an offer to play magnus group
to join chess.com magnus carlson and the
management at play magnus are
enthusiastic and have accepted the offer
we expect that it will take about six to
eight weeks for this process to finalize
until that time chess.com and play
magnus will remain independent companies
and there's um more in the article but
if you guys are interested do check it
out so that's basically about the news
what this means for chess for the
community for the entire world uh only
time will tell but you know things are
definitely changing now getting back to
this game it's truly a wild one no
wonder so many of you have suggested it
um international master matthew
wattsworth versus video master harry
grieve like i said from the chestable
british championship and it's uh from
the final round and it really is an
important game as
i don't want to spoil too much but one
of these two gentlemen uh has won the
entire event so let's check it out as uh
there are there's quite a lot to enjoy
and many many queens will be on the
board so here we have pawn to c4 matthew
opens with the english opening with e6
the aegean core defense g3 d5
and now bishop to g2 and getting the
bishop to the long diagonal we have c6
and now knight to f3 we have d captures
on c4 and this is a fairly standard
position you will see something like a4
here you will see castles here but here
matthew goes for knight to a3 and it's a
very very tricky idea a very sneaky move
uh that sort of baits the black to go
pawn to b5 now it's um
it's basically a question do you want to
give up your bishop mess up my pawn
structure bishop capture spawn captures
and this is most likely okay for black
but obviously white prepared this and
maybe
you know white will have the edge of
preparation
uh so here instead we have ponte b5 but
this is already uh well it's not a
blunder or anything like that but it's
uh you know
an imprecision to put it mildly
because after b5 here matthew just
played knight captures on b5 and it
looks like okay i'm going to capture
you're going to move your
knight that the bishop will be attacking
the rook can't i do something about this
well not really because after c captures
on b5 the question is where do you move
the knight and you can't move it to e5
because if you move it the e5 just
knights the d7 you've already given up a
knight for the rook now if you give up
another knight you're not gonna
be gaining all that much and if you go
for something like uh knight captures
here just bishop captures and now the
queen defends the rook so after for
example bishop captures queen captures
black will be up too much material and
this is already winning for black
another thing after c captures on b5 you
could play knights to h4 now this also
opens up an attack towards the rook but
then g5 and again you don't really have
a good reply to this you just have to go
for bishop captures uh and then
the knight is captured and black will
have one two pieces for the rook which
of course is uh
much much better for black but there is
this knight the g1 move and the knight
simply cannot be attacked on g1 it is
impossible and next move bishop captures
rook and a8 is coming uh and there's
really no good way to stop this see if
you play knight the c6 check that maybe
give up the knight of course it's
impossible because this comes with check
so here we have bishop to d7 and now
bishop captures an a8 so okay black wins
the exchange and after knight to c6 we
even have a bishop captures bishop
captures and not knight to f3 as the
rook was attacked knight to f6 now comes
b3 challenging this advanced pawn
structure here and bishop to c5 we have
bishop to beat
you in keto ink and now queen to d5 so
black did get some development in black
does have the bishop pair uh but all in
all white is just up material uh so here
b captures in c4 b captures and even
bishop captures an f6 giving up both of
the bishops and it's uh its principle
decision you are up in material you want
to trade down as much as possible g
captures on f6 queen to c2 and now king
to e7 we have rooked the c1 now
preparing to grab the pawn here uh
bishop to a3 not allowing this kicking
away the rook so rook to b1 and now
bishop back to
the d6
saying that if you try and repeat this i
am
more than happy with a perpetual here so
here we have queen to c3 and now queen
to e4 we have rook to c1 again preparing
to capture the pawn and now bishop to d5
now harry cements the position very
nicely we have queen to a5 and now rook
to a8 defending the pawn on a7 we have
king to f1 and now pawn to f5 we have
pawn to h4 and now queen the g for now
preparing to capture with the bishop on
f3 so here we have queen sorry not queen
to a3 that would be terrible queen c3
adding another defender to the knight
and now pawn to f4 and if you don't want
to see f captures on g3 you definitely
want to capture the pawn
so g captures and now rook the g8 even
though black is down in material black
has a very very active play and the
white has to be incredibly precise not
to just blunder the entire game away
for example if you play something like
rook to g1 seems like a good idea just
queen h3 check and it's game over after
the the king moves just bishop captures
on f3 removes the defender of the rook
and even if you capture here you just
get checkmated queen h1 rook g1 queen
the g1 will be checkmate so after this
rook the g8 move we've kinked the e1
and now bishop captures an f4 just
reclaiming the pawn queen to a3 with
check king to f6 and now rook to f1 we
have rooked the d8
and now we have queen to c3 with check
pawn to e5 and now rook to g1
challenging the black queen so queen to
h5 and now queen to a5 and this is the
only good way for white to continue go
after the pawn if the pawn is defended
then you can start harassing the black
king a little bit so rook d7 defending
the entire seventh rank queen to a6
check with king the e7 and now queen
back to a3 with check king f6 again
black very happy with the repetition you
are attacking but um
uh you know if white defends you're just
down material so rook to c2 and now
queen to f5 uh attacking the rook on c2
so rook back to b2 and now bishop to e6
uh and here what do you play uh here
queen to c3 was played but you could
also consider a move like e3 i'm just
going to show it because it's super fun
it seems like it's a weird move to make
because the knight is now undefended so
just moving the bishop should work for
black
but it doesn't because if you move for
example bishop captures here white can
capture and if rook to d3 saying okay
now i'm gonna capture the knight there's
queen g5 check and this comes with check
of course and after queen captures h
captures comes with check and now after
the king moves you're just going to move
the knight or defend the knight and now
you're just up in material and winning
and another thing is after um this e3
move at bishop captures you don't even
have to capture with the queen you can
actually capture with the f-pawn as well
because if queen captures rook f1 just
wins the queen so e3 was definitely a
move to consider here but okay queen to
c3 was played with h6 now taking away
that g5 square from white's pieces as
you've seen how deadly it could be
rook to b5 now stopping any advancements
of the pawn for the moment you can't
push the pawn but if the king moves then
of course the pawn wants to march
forward uh queen to e4 and now king to
d1
uh we have bishop to f5 now if the white
queen moves from the defense of the c2
squared and we just have a very nice
queen c2 queen c1 checkmate so here rook
back to b2 gaining more control over the
c to square and now comes rook to d3 a
beautiful beautiful move by harry
uh offering a full rook uh but for what
that that's the question so what can you
play here if you do absolutely nothing
you could play something like knights to
g5 this is possible uh but rook captures
on f3 is basically the idea if the queen
moves you could play something like
queen to a5 offer offer the knight and
then try to harass the king from the d8
square this is possible uh but also
knights the g5 is very nice i'm just
going to show it for example knight g5 h
captured h captures with checking after
bishop captures now you accept the rook
and now after queen to f3 check king to
c1 queen captures on f2 attacks the rook
for example rook goes here bishop
captures on d3 it's similar to what
happened in the game without the knight
actually being traded
but you get this position where white
kind of should be better but why would
you rather play here white or black i
mean the bishop bear those are absolute
monsters uh i i mean
everyone takes black here
so in the game uh white accepted the
rook e captures on d3 we have queen
captures on f3 with check king to c1 and
now bishop captures and d3 so it's a
basically a position where a bishop
player is fighting against the rook pair
but the rook bear uh really has no files
to uh to use to attack the black king
and the bishop the bishops are just
monsters this is basically the
definition of the bishop's pair from
hell so here we have rook to b4 and now
queen captures on f2 attacking this rook
so rook to h1 and now pawn to h5 not
allowing this pawn to advance any
further keeping it as a target here
we have rook to a4 going after the a7
pawn but for the moment it is defended
you could also use it to deliver some
checks along the uh the sixth rank so
here a5 uh it's a very cheeky move
uh point is if the a pawn is captured a
white uh just crumbles for example if
queen captures on a5 just queen to d4
and now you can't there's no defense
against queen day one checkmate that's
just it the king has no no good squares
uh and if you try for example rook
captures here then it's also a very nice
queen to b6 uh now attacking putting
pressure on drug but basically just uh
threatening checkmate so the queen can't
really be used to defend against
checkmate something like queen to b2
then just the rook falls so you'd have
to play king to d1 but it's not enough
queen to be one with check and once the
queen defends there's the uh well there
you can play bishop captures here this
also works but um
sorry bishop to c to check this also
works but uh queen to b6 uh sorry queen
to b7 is actually the move that wins the
game on the spot i mean just a beautiful
beautiful uh uh continuation here with
black you're attacking the rook and
there's no way to defend it once you
move the rook queen to f3 check uh we'll
deliver check king e1 and then of course
queen to e2 will be checkmate and
there's no good defense uh against this
so uh those are your options if you
actually capture the pawn so the a5 pawn
is uh well the
the the most poisonous pawn you you've
ever seen so here rook to d1 a very very
nice way of defending because now the
same idea no longer applies here we have
queen to b6 and now queen to b2 this can
now be played because you don't have to
worry about bishop captures here
otherwise queen captures would just be
met with uh queen b1 checkmate
uh and now you could capture easily with
uh with the rook or if there wasn't
there for example captures captures you
lose the queen so the rook is essential
here so queen to c5 now we have rook to
a3 and now king to f5 now black wants to
get the king deeper into the position
and even if pieces get traded down then
maybe those pawns can start marching
forward we have queen to c3
now again putting pressure on the a5
pawn and queen b5 again threatening
checkmate sorry i don't know why i
played queen b6 queen b5 threatening
checkmate uh queen b2 again defending
and now queen to c6 now we have queen
back to c3 white would be very happy
with a draw here now but black just
continues pawn to f6 and offers the a5
pawn but the difference is now the pawn
can be captured we have queen captures
on a5 queen to b7 again threatening
checkmate and now uh you can't really uh
uh put anything to to block this
checkmate so you have to play rook
captures on d3 it is the only move that
uh keeps white in the game so rook
captures uh c captures on d3 and now
queen to c3 and okay now white has a
past pawn white is still up the exchange
but if black gets those pawns marching
forward uh anything could happen so here
we have queen to a6 queen to b3 and now
we have king to e4 we have pawn to a4
and now king to f3 and here uh there is
um
a a very interesting continuation for
example if you go queen to d5 check it's
basically a force to draw king to f2
you're gonna play queen to c5 with chuck
king to e2 and now you can play rook t1
check give up a rook and you have a
perpetual queen to g1 and now of course
there's only two squares king e2 queen
g2 checking you one queen the g1 check
king e2 queen g2 and so on you get a
nice draw but here in the game uh rook
the e1 was played and i mean why not now
queen f queen to d1 check is possible
and if white is allowed to play this
then black will just get checkmated
but here white missed one a very
important move so feel free to pause the
video and try to win the game but not
just the game in the entire chessable um
british championship for harry while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh moving even
deeper into the position with your king
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is king to f2 this uh
prevents queen to d1 as it no longer
comes with check now if you try
something like queen to d1 uh there's
really no point because just queen to c
for check and after uh let's say king to
b2 you're gonna play queen to b for
czech king the a1 now i play queen to a3
with check king to b1 and now uh
or rather even uh you don't have to
deliver this check you can just play
bishop captures here and there is no uh
way to to save this game once you get
out of checks just bishop the c3 will
end the game for example you you deliver
one check king to e3 and now uh there
really isn't all that much you can do
you can play queen to f3 king to d4 but
the black king escapes there are just
too many pawns and the bishop is here so
you can uh
easily hide let's say queen f2 king the
c3 and now there really aren't no more
useful checks and that's just it now you
get checkmated so that's uh uh
what happens if you play queen to d1 now
so in the game rook to e4 was played but
now point to f5 everything comes now
with tempo the rook is attacked rook to
c4 and now pawn to e4 and now look at
this beautiful structure here we have
queen to c3 now comes king to e2 we have
pawn to a5 and now queen to h6 now
putting pressure on the d2 pawn and
there's no way to defend the bishop
captures is coming it is attacked three
times uh so there's no way to save it so
you have to play king to b1 if you don't
want to lose your queen bishop captures
on d2 now queen to b2 and the now queen
to e6 attacking the rook here so rook to
c5 and now pawn to f4
we have queen to b5 now comes pawn to f3
rook to e5 attacks the queen just queen
to g6 we have pawn to a6 white will get
another queen into the game but so will
black pawn to f2 we have rook to f5 uh
keeping an eye on the f1 square you will
you have you will have to give up your
rook for the pawn at some point uh
bishop to e3 now uh and queen to b2 with
check we have d2
and now pawn to a7 uh there's uh
no good way to play this uh bishop
captures is possible but there's no
reason to do it right away so queen
captures an f5 a8 bring you a queen into
the game and now f1 bringing the queen
into the game with check so now there
are four queens on the board but as it
often is the player who delivers the
queen into the game with check
usually has a force continuation and
that this game is no different here we
have king to a2 but now it's a forced
checkmate in uh six and there are quite
a few ways to do it you could play queen
f7 queen the e6 check in the game e6
check was played king a3 bishop to c5
with check king a4 and now queen the c4
with check we have king to a5 and now a
beautiful finish a nice queen sacrifice
for checkmate it's not uh as impressive
as you have more than one queen but
still queen to a1 with check queen
captures on a1 and now queen to b4 check
forcing the king to a6 and now queen to
b6 is checkmate so really a spectacular
game where uh you you have a perfect
example of how uh
uh
one player gets outplayed right out of
the opening here matthew really really
surprised um harry with this uh a night
move and he really gets the advantage
but even though this is sort of an
advantage uh because uh let's say okay
let's uh throw in a few more moves okay
this is the position uh you have a rook
for for a bishop um and you are of
course clearly better and you know that
you are clearly better but you've seen
how how uh much easier it is to find
moves for black than it is to find moves
for white as the bishop fair is just so
strong uh it's uh very hard to stress
this enough like when you're at the
absolute top level like maybe 2700 okay
then you will take maybe advantage of
this position with white uh but uh not
every game you know it's uh so just
because you win the exchange your
opponent uh you know you won the rogue
but your opponent gains this diagonal
for the rest of the game uh it's
definitely a trade-off i wouldn't call
that um gaining an advantage but a very
interesting game and uh harry doesn't
win just this game but he also wins the
entire chesable british championship
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that little bit of news
at the beginning um about the uh sort of
the acquisition of play magnus group
vhs.com so hope you enjoyed that as well
uh i would like to thank gabriel
rodriguez evan sterling john austin
andrei schrader and dixit varma for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day